and
[Music]
welcome to fiesta latina for 18 years
the day and barí misión and the
action pressure boards came together to have
this wonderful celebration of fiesta
latina that in 2020 we are
moving it to a virtual environment together with
the new haven to  dance see and the
Latino ideal of working group and I discovered in
bartender fiesta latina is a celebration
of traditional and contemporary
Latin American culture and it is a
magnificent opportunity to have our voices here become
scientific whether you are an artist a
leader whoever is
all together during the latino be  the
most to work and learn in order to
have a fairer and more
sustainable future we want to thank band
grid our sponsor for the opportunity
to have this latin party this year and we
want to invite all of you
to participate in all the other
events we have  organized
we are waiting for you
[Music]